we're used to dividing how people vote
in elections according to the categories
of right wing and left wing but there
might be another way of labeling an
electorate that taps into something
broader and deeper in human personality
we might apportion people into the camps
of romantic and classical voters which
one might you be part of here is some of
what separates these two fundamental
electoral types
romantic believes that a far better
world could be just around the corner
if only bold and swift action could be
taken if we entered an agreement or
scrapped an agreement started a war or
ended a war the romantic considers a
degree of impatience to be a vital
resource in governing a nation they may
not think too badly of a bit of anger
either so long as it's handled correctly
you can be too forgiving after all the
romantic is excited by how things might
ideally be and always judges what
currently exists in the world by the
standard of a better imagined
alternative most of the time the current
state of things arouses them to intense
disappointment as they consider the
injustice a--'s prevarications
compromises and timidity of almost
everyone in government for their part
the classical voter is highly
distrustful of sudden gestures and
actions they pay special attention to
what can go wrong they're very concerned
to mitigate the downside they're aware
that most things could be a lot worse
before condemning a policy they consider
the standard of policy across history
and may regard a current arrangement as
bearable under the circumstances their
view of people is fundamentally rather
dark they believe that everyone is
probably slightly worse than they seem
they feel humans have deeply dangerous
impulses lusts and drives and believe
that the task of politics is to try and
contain them rather than liberate genius
strength beauty or benevolence high
ideals make them nervous they are led by
a desire not to make anything worse
insofar as they hope for improvement
it's in a cautious modest way they dare
to suppose that the world may be a
marginally better place in about 300
years time
romantics see a lot that's wrong with
the world and feel confident about
analyzing who might be to blame for it
perhaps this particular social group or
that class a problem can't just be no
one's fault and therefore the task of
politics is to identify the wrongdoers
and respond appropriately romantics feel
a basic trust in their own capacity for
purity they are sure they would be
unable to be as shabby as their enemies
whom they can therefore attack with a
relatively clean conscience classical
voters also notice what's wrong but
they're highly aware of their own
capacity for sinfulness and error which
makes them hesitant about apportioning
blame they recognize how easily they
might have been active wrongdoers if
circumstances have been different and
suppose that no one has a monopoly on
righteousness they would suggest that
evil is pretty proportionately
distributed across all groups and
classes and that a priority is therefore
for us to tolerantly cut each other
slack at every turn
romantic voters believe that everything
great in history is the result of
talented individuals taking destiny into
their hands and struggling against the
inertia and conservatism of the mass and
most importantly of institutions
classical voters are deeply worried by
the possibility of lone actors taking
matters into their hands and through
natural weaknesses which all of us even
the most intelligent are afflicted by
creating disaster they are therefore on
the side of legally grounded extremely
slow-moving institutions that are
designed to restrain individual power
and contain the capacity of any one
person to shift the direction of the
group to quickly romantic voters believe
it's possible to understand a
situational issue so clearly one can be
sure of complete justice and rightness
vertol those who don't agree don't have
to be listened to politely they are
evidently wrong and can be silenced or
sidelined as required
classical voters are extremely alert to
the possibility of error in their own
and others analyses of policy but they
are therefore committed to hearing and
tolerating dissenting views in which
they suspect a portion of the truth may
always be lodged
[Music]
romantic voters feel that the best way
for a nation to be safe in the world is
for it to seem prominently strong
classical voters feel that the best way
to be safe in the world is to be thought
well of and will therefore avoid actions
that could upset alarm or confuse
neighbors they're aware of how easily
strength arouses the desire of others to
be equally strong back they suspect the
best way to proceed might be to train
and private for the worst but extend a
hand of friendship at every public turn
both romantic and classical political
orientations have important truths to
impart neither is wholly right or wrong
they need to be balanced and none of us
are in any case ever simply one or the
other but because a good political
landscape requires a judicious balance
of throath temperaments at this point in
history in many countries it might be
the classical electoral attitude whose
distinctive claims and wisdom we need to
listen to most intently and which is
most ripe for rediscovery
you